shailene woodley and aaron rodgers
continue to spend time together let's
just throw it out there and judging by
these snaps the actress and nfl star may
not be forfeiting their romance
in new photos they're seen exiting a
private jet in palm beach florida
keeping it casual chalene wears a black
hoodie jeans boots and her hair in a
high bun meanwhile erin also dons a
hoodie adding sweatpants sneakers and
aviators to his ensemble this is just
one of the few spottings after the stars
called off their engagement last month
now source explained to e.t aaron had
told shailene he'll put more effort into
the relationship and making her a
priority the two have been spending more
time together recently and we'll see
what the future holds their florida
getaway comes days after attending a
wedding together over the weekend they
were on hand to celebrate aaron's
packers teammate david bakhtiari saying
i do on saturday in california
according to an eyewitness at the
wedding aaron and shaylene even packed
on a little pda
the eyewitness tells e.t the pair was
walking arm and arm on their way to the
reception ballroom so what does that
mean for their relationship status
nobody knows the full story the rumor
mill is speculating aaron and shaylene
are rekindling their romance but nothing
is confirmed following their split in
february a source told et at the time
busy careers in different industries
made it difficult to see each other the
source added the two have no animosity
toward one another and plan to remain as
friends
last year shailene revealed to jimmy
fallon that she and the nfl pro were
engaged not long after they started
dating during the pandemic yes we are
engaged we are engaged he's first off
just a wonderful incredible human being
but i never thought i'd be engaged with
somebody who threw balls for a living
like i never thought as a little girl i
was like yeah when i grow up i'm gonna
marry someone who
who throws balls yeah
um but he's really just so good at it
[Music]